An aurora shimmers the night sky.
And for a moment, a startling, seemingly alien
realm becomes illuminated.
This is the world of Serina… and despite
appearances, these are not aliens, but the
descendants of birds… and fish.
We’ve been following this saga for several
videos, watching as, over the past two hundred
and eighty million years, an initial group
of finches and other creatures left on a distant
moon have evolved into a dizzying variety
of forms.
When we last checked in, this world had been
flung into cataclysm, and the intelligent
Sea Stewards had been transported away to
another realm.
Now, Serina is beginning to recover from the
loss of its top species — although the greatest
dangers and most extortionary lifeforms still
lie ahead.
So, let’s return to this world of birds,
and remember to support creator Dylan Bajda
on Patreon using the links below.
Our journey begins with the rising sun.
Here in the Northern Soglands, the morning
rays illuminate a varied tapestry of life.
Thorngrazers feed upon the sodden plant matter
and unleash their bellowing calls.
A predatory Drakevulture scours for prey from
above.
The towering Watchtower Wumpos loom over the
entire scene.
These species represent some of the lineages
that will come to prominence in this new era.
We are now in The Hothouse Age, and the lands
of Serina have become splintered by the highest-ever
sea level.
Though volcanism is on the decline and the
end of this world looms ever closer — an
atmosphere heavy in carbon-dioxide means Serina
has never been so warm… or so conducive
to radical experimentation.
On the inland floodplains, a monstrous descendant
of the Burrowing Burdle attempts to bring
down a smaller Hoglump, while a Foxtrotter
watches from the branches.
All three species have had to radically change
their behavior in a short period to survive.
On the ever-shifting coast, adaptability is
even more essential.
This tentacled Shorescrounger and their chicks
are just humble scavengers at present — but
there’s no telling what the future will
bring.
From the water emerges a Sandlubber — a
kind of semi-terrestrial snail.
To the Shorescroungers, it looks like breakfast.
In the open sea, other snail-descendants are
enjoying a buffet of their own.
The snaggletoothed Calacarna have become huge
apex predators, and their preferred prey — the
Escardines — are also a type of marine snail.
The seas belong to the invertebrates now,
and as the eons pass, the gastropods’ grip
upon the marine ecosystem will only tighten
as larger and larger species arise in the
post-ice-age waters.
Some, like the Spikerays, will proliferate
under the murky surface of freshwater rivers
in astonishingly high numbers — their body-plans
converging upon that of modern ray species.
Another dawn comes to this brave new world.
On the northern coast of Serinaustra, the
body of a titanic Shimmershiner — currently
the largest marine snail species — washes
up on the sands.
All manner of carnivores quickly descend upon
this rare feast.
There’s no time to take turns.
Eventually, night falls, and a very peculiar
creature emerges to assess what remains of
the carcass.
It’s a Nightcreeper — another Burrowing
Burdle descendant that’s strictly nocturnal.
The early bird might get the biggest portion,
but the Nightcreeper has carved out a niche
for itself snatching up midnight leftovers.
Of course, not everyone has to stress about
sticking to the shadows.
The omnivorous Skoblin — descendants of
the otter-like skuorc birds — have arrived
upon a rather imposing body plan.
The future of this lineage will be very bright
indeed.
More familiar dynasties flourish in one of
the last relatively dry biomes on Serina — the
Uplands.
Here, members of the Battering Helmethead
Thorngrazer species clash over territory close
to a herd of Jumpo Wumpos.
A relative of the Watchtower Wumpos, they’re
far from the strangest trunked bird species
in this era.
In the southern jungles, for example, the
speedy Lumpelopes race through the underbrush,
their facial flanges displaying bright colors
to attract mates.
In the polar basin, the peculiar Shucklumps
have turned their trunks into a means of prying
open shellfish for an easy meal.
The Shucklumps appear nonthreatening, but
the Laship Carnackles — an emergent carnivorous
trunk bird, appear anything but.
And in this case, appearances aren’t deceiving:
the Lashlips are ruthlessly effective hunters.
The Hothouse age can be ruthless, but it can
also be a stage for unexpectedly touching
moments.
Here, a mother Bloblump — the most rotund
of the trunk birds — has taken in a rather
confused Foxtrotter, who has gained the scent
of her young after spending time in their
vicinity.
Though its roaming instincts will eventually
cause this Foxtrotter to wander on, it is
nice to be part of a family — if just for
a day.
Not long ago, Serina was a haven for this
sort of cross-species cooperation.
But the most intelligent and altruistic species
have all since vanished — displaced to another
world or rendered extinct by the calamity
that capped off the previous era.
Though deeply tragic, this loss has left behind
an intriguing intelligence vacuum.
Back on the coast, the Shorescroungers have
begun to diversify, with some new offshoots
becoming increasingly social.
It’s a development to keep an eye on…
As the Houthouse age wears on, new forest
ecosystems offer new ways of life.
Here, a Gravedigger subspecies sinks its teeth
into a hapless Thorngrazer.
You wouldn’t know it by glancing at the
predator, but its distant relatives — the
Thalassic Gravediggers, were once one of the
most intelligent species on Serina.
Elsewhere in the forest, however, a different
subspecies is following more closely in the
Thalassic Gravedigger’s footsteps.
This is a Spirepryer, a primitive tool user
who feeds on Honey Ants.
They’re a reasonably brainy bird: although
not half as clever as their Thalassic relatives.
Another species with a remarkable ancestry
is the Skreehonk.
These long-necked herbivores are members of
the Giraffowl — an emerging clade that,
like earth giraffes, browse on vegetation
that most grazers simply can’t reach.
But where did such an unusual clade emerge
from?
They’re actually the distant descendants
of the Seraphs, who once reigned supreme in
Serina’s skies.
One small surviving lineage, the Fallen Angels,
found a niche scavenging on the ground, becoming
increasingly well-adapted for terrestrial
locomotion.
From this initial Giraffowl body plan, a wide
variety of unusual offshoots have emerged.
And over the next several million years, this
group will only become stranger.
But for now, the Giraffefowl have competition
in the Hothouse forests from Spiral Sirenhorns
— a type of Thorngrazer with an elaborate
nasal structure that produces eerie musical
calls.
These pack animals have reached impressive
sizes, converging on a niche similar to modern
bison.
Yet both the Sirenhorns and the Giraffefowl
need to keep an eye on a new upstart.
Soggoblers are huge, aggressive creatures
related to the Skoblins that seem poised to
follow in the titanic footsteps of Earth sauropods.
And while the Soggoblers are herbivores, the
related Skogres have a taste for meat as well
as veggies.
At three and a half meters, or twelve feet
tall, the only thing more formidable than
their monstrous size is their monstrous appetite.
A group of Skogre can strip a small island
of vegetation in just a few weeks, before
crossing the water to do the same thing to
another landmass.
One might assume that nothing could rival
their destructive power…
…But in the southern bogs, an even more
ravenous force is waiting.
This trunked bird… is about to fall prey
to the insatiable Bog Shogoth.
A superorganism made up of thousands of cooperating
ants, Bog Shogoths are the ultimate scavengers.
Though slightly less aggressive than their
ice age ancestors, the Sea Shogoths, the fact
such a deadly lineage has endured into the
Hothouse era could spell trouble for the age
to come.
It’s a good time to be up in the branches.
The forest canopy is now home to not just
bird descendants, but snail descendants as
well.
The peculiar Tree Gups are derived from marine
snails that became amphibious during the start
of the Hothouse, and are now well adapted
for a wooded environment.
Once, the woods of Serina were tended to by
the Antlears — one of the first intelligent
tool users who tragically faded from history
long ago.
Though their allies, the Gravediggers, preserved
their memory for a time, the Gravediggers
have now also disappeared from Serina’s
surface.
But while these Antlears are long extinct,
one lone relative, the Surivears, have endured
into the middle Hothouse.
And as a changing climate turns marshland
to savannah, the Antlears have an incredible
opportunity to adapt...
We now return to the image of the aurora-lit
swampland.
This scene takes place in Serina’s warm
southern pole, where for several months, the
sun does not rise.
And in the darkness…
evolution has sired creatures never-before-seen.
Shimmering bioluminescence — a rare sight
in terrestrial organisms, lights up sections
of the polar forest.
On the forest floor, a Digdag — another
Burrowing Bundle descendant scrounges for
a meal.
Close to this badger-sized lifeform is a fan
club of smaller fliers, who are hopeful the
Digdag will uncover something they can steal.
But all smaller lifeforms need to tread carefully,
for the uncanny Spook hides in the shroud
of night.
A member of the batlike lineage of tribbats,
the Spook’s large ears form a dish-like
structure that allows them to hone in on the
slightest sound.
Yet Spooks are not the canniest hunters in
the Longdark Swamp.
Something very special has emerged in this
darkness: a new tool user.
Squabgoblins are relatives of Shorescroungers
that have put their tentacles to work crafting
rudimentary spears.
This, combined with their ability to hunt
in packs, have made these tiny terrors formidable
indeed.
Though the Squabgoblins currently lack the
true spark of sapience, there is enough kindling
here to one day, hopefully, reignite the lost
fire of advanced intelligence…
And observing the Squabgoblins is another
bright-eyed bird species.
Bogglebirds are clever omnivores who have
learned to act as watchdogs for the Squabgoblins
in exchange for food.
Perhaps they, too, will carry the torch of
intelligence onwards…
For now, day is breaking at last after many
months of darkness.
And with the light come the Dawnwalkers — large
bipedal herbivores that hibernate during the
winter, only to reawaken when the sun and
the greenery returns.
And they aren’t the only giants who return
with the sun.
Huge Giraffefowl called Crowncrested Skybreakers
descend upon the forest, coming home following
their long migration north for the duration
of the winter.
During the height of summer, the southern
swamp becomes almost unrecognizable as biodiversity
increases.
One rather unassuming species, the aquatic
Rivercarver, acts as steward of this biodiversity.
Like earth beavers, Rivercarvers are ecosystem
engineers, damming and shifting the flow of
freshwater to create an optimal environment
in which to raise their young.
A parent must do what they can — for it’s
a dangerous world out there.
Some of the largest birds ever seen on Serina
now prowl the northern continent.
Descendants of the Soggobblers, the Cygnosaurs
might technically be herbivores, but they’re
hardly strict vegetarians.
These aggressive creatures will happily supplement
their diet with small animal life should the
need arise — including chicks of their own
species.
Though this tree will keep these hatchings
safe, with the rise of the Cygnosaurs, survival
on Serina now is far more challenging.
It’s a good time to have allies.
The Superb Squaboon are relatives of the Longdark
Squabgoblins that have learned to cooperate
in packs and craft simple tools.
And they’re not the only crafty tentacle-bird
on the block.
The unusual Boomer Squaboon also operates
in clans, and have learned to build traps
to catch fish — although the primary function
of their strange tentacles is to amplify their
mating calls like a megaphone.
Next to these species, the Bloodbreasted Squaboon
doesn’t seem to have much going for it beyond
an unusual hue.
Yet out of all the Squaboons, they are the
ones with the grandest destiny…
For now, the end of the Hothouse age is looming
ever closer.
Yet before this era comes to a close, a final
specular environment will emerge…
We are now two-hundred and ninety-million
years into the Serina experiment.
And though tectonic shifts have slowed to
a crawl, new mountains rise against the distant
sky.
These Sky Islands are actually vast terrestrial
reefs formed from layers of Spire Trees — and
they serve as a stage for remarkable new evolutionary
dramas.
Gliding between the cliffs is a Superb Sky
Serpent.
A type of limbless Skuorc, these hunters can
soar for short distances by catching air underneath
their parachute-like bodies, much like Draco
lizards here on Earth.
Other snake-like predators have a different
tactic for getting the drop on prey.
Cliff Strikeworms lurk in the crevices of
the Sky Islands, lashing out with their curved
mandibles to ensnare anything unlucky enough
to be caught unaware.
But the crags of the Sky islands don’t just
hide predators — they also conceal prey.
Here, an herbivorous Starrybara takes shelter
from the long posterior limb of a Skyheel.
A bite from the Starrybara’s beak might
be enough to dissuade the Skyheel from digging
deeper into its domain — although in the
game of life, these two species are well matched…
The Sky Islands are one of many new fields
of competition in the late Hothouse.
In the arctic, a northern equivalent to the
Longdark Swamp has emerged in the form of
the Night Forest.
This massive vertical ecosystem is home to
trees so tall that the branches feel like
an entirely separate world from the forest
floor.
Over one hundred meters, or three hundred
and fifty feet off the ground, a Red Rasp
rests in the branches.
Though their hooked tongue appears fearsome,
the Rasp primarily feeds on insect larva that
they dig from the bark of trees.
A world away on the forest floor, the baffling
Prismuffalope also enjoys the occasional insect
snack.
A descendant of the Battering Helmetheads,
Prismuffalopes sport highly unusual heads
crests both to impress mates, and scare off
rivals.
At the very edge of the Nightforest, a tiny
equine-like relative Prismuffalope, the Equinox,
is about to be preyed upon by the Ruffled
Rasp — a relative of the Red Rasp.
It’s a tricky task for such a small predator,
but these unusual times call for risky behavior.
For the late hothouse is an era of uncertainty.
In the oceans, life is increasingly pushed
to the coast as the global climate wreaks
havoc on deep water environments.
The result is a shallow water ecosystem of
extreme competition— and extreme lifeforms.
One of the most unusual are the Wandering
Whelicans — new arrivals on the aquatic
scene that, despite appearances, are actually
the descendants of tentacled Shorescroungers
that took to the sea.
Like earth whales, Whelicans have evolved
to filter feed, and have radiated out into
a number of unusual forms — including the
Striker Whelican, whose outer two tentacles
have elongated into highly effective fish-catchers.
Yet as predators, the Whelican’s pale in
comparison to the colossal Kraviathans — the
single largest hunters ever to exist on Serina.
Exceeding fifty-two feet, or sixteen meters
in length and weighing up to forty tons, these
giants are, amazingly, yet another descendant
of marine slugs.
Though the end of this world creeps ever-closer,
Serina has entered an age of giants — where
predator and prey clash like never before.
In the southern pole, a giant Dawnwalker tries
to frighten off a sleek Fanguar.
Fanguars are capable hunters, but this one
isn’t fully grown yet, and might be in over
its head given the size of its quarry.
In the Sky Islands, a far smaller drama unfolds
between a Painted Jackalope and a long-toothed
Goatsucker.
Neither species weighs more than two kilograms,
or four pounds — but their will to survive
is no less fierce than the largest of Serina’s
animals.
And speaking of… on the northern continent,
certain Cygnosaurs are now among the largest
animals ever to walk on Serina.
But with exceptional prey comes exceptional
predators.
Subjugators are a relatively new guild of
megafaunal bipedal tribbetheres large enough
to pose a threat to juvenile Cygnosaurs.
Skirmishes between these two groups are often
awe-inspiring — a clash of titans not seen
since the Mesozoic of Earth.
Relatives of the Cygnosaurs, the Regal Skulossi,
also seem like something out of the age of
dinosaurs.
These huge Skuorcs might appear too large
to be under threat of predation… but the
late Hothouse is a time of monsters.
The Imperious River Dragon is a leviathan
large enough to drag Skulossi into the murky
depths.
When pondering such a beast, it’s easy to
think of nature as a constant escalation of
violence.
But nature has a silly side as well.
Elsewhere on the northern continent, Bowerbuck
are a type of Giraffowl that work hard to
construct colorful towers of vegetation to
impress potential mates.
This sort of behavior can attract predators
as well — but such are the perils of love.
Some love stories are wholly unique.
Here, a male Flutterfox is trying to court
a large female Moonbeast.
These two species aren’t closely related,
but the Flutterfox doesn’t seem deterred.
It’s a small reminder that the engine of
nature will create sights one might never
expect.
Wandering Spiderweeds are a type of carnivorous
plant that have learned to ‘move’ through
a cycle of continuous leaf replacement.
They aren’t particularly quick — only
able to move around two meters, or six feet
per year — but they’re an intriguing species
that has quietly evolved in the background
of Serina.
And on the subject of species that have evolved
in the background, Antlears have now diversified
into numerous successful forms.
Buldozears are large omnivores with antlers
powerful enough to stun both predators, and
mating rivals.
Other Bulldozears have evolved hooked antlers
designed for quick slashes.
Though none of these Antlears have continued
to carry the torch of intelligence their Woodcrafter
cousins once bore, they are nonetheless capable
lifeforms in their own right.
Considering Serina’s current biodiversity,
it is difficult to imagine that the end is
near.
The northern Polar Basin, for example, has
never been as rich with life as it is two
hundred and ninety million years post establishment.
But there are warning signs on the horizon
that cannot be ignored.
As volcanism continues to decline, Serina’s
magnetic field weakens — and with it, the
atmosphere has started to thin, allowing for
increased harmful radiation to reach the planet’s
surface.
The final chapter has come at last.
As a mass extinction looms on the surface,
it is time we briefly turn our attention to
a hidden world below.
For underneath the exterior of Serina is a
network of chambers home to long forgotten
lineages that have had eons to adapt to the
dark.
Very little of the life within these caverns
is currently known, but as the surface declines,
an underground world might rise…
Back on the surface, somewhere in the Longdark
Swamp, a group of Squabgoblins and Bogglebirds
watch the setting sun.
A cold snap has frozen the marsh solid, and
though this dip in temperature will not last,
it is a sign of more permanent changes to
come.
Will Serina’s burgeoning intelligent life
be able to adapt in time?
Jumping forward a brief five million years
beyond the end of the Hothouse age, a family
of Flutterfoxes watch a forest fire engulf
their environment.
Rain no longer extinguishes these brushfires
as the atmosphere continues to weaken.
The end is very close indeed.
But here in Serina’s twilight hours, Sapience
has returned at last.
The Bloodbreasted Squaboon of ages past have
given rise to the Sylvanspark — a highly
social species that is beginning to craft
complex tools.
And they’re not the only tool-using tentacle
bird.
They share this world with the Slaughtersprinters
— descendants of Squabgoblins who have taken
to the plains following the collapse of the
Longdark Swamp ecosystem.
And their Bogglebird allies have achieved
advanced intelligence as well, becoming the
artistically inclined Whisperwings.
All three species have arisen in close proximity
to each other — and their futures shall
be deeply intertwined.
But is it too little too late?
With the age of giants coming to a crashing
close and global temperatures dropping, it
is unclear what hope these new sophonts have.
Serina has always been a story of hope and
tragedy, of joy and sorrow.
Whatever the future holds, life is always
full of surprises…
The final chapter of the End Ultimocene is
still to come.
But that’s all I can give away for now.
If you enjoy this series as much as I do,
once again there are links to Dylan Bajda’s
Patreon and the Patreon of guest artist TrollMan
in the description.
And by the way, as always, thank you for watching.
If you enjoyed this video and want to support
the channel, consider liking, subscribing,
and hitting the notification icon to stay
up to date on all things curious.
See you in the next video.